-The president is facing
an independent challenge
from the former C.E.O.
of Starbucks
and a tell-all book
from a former aide.
For more on this, it's time for
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
President Trump's approval
ratings are record lows,
and there are already
several prominent Democrats
with serious track records
lining up to run against him.
And then,
there's Howard Schultz,
the billionaire former C.E.O.
of Starbucks.
Schultz has been
attacking Democrats,
and says he wants to run
a centrist, independent
campaign for president.
And so far, the rollout
has been a disaster.
-Former Starbucks C.E.O.
Howard Schultz
got an earful
from a protester
at a New York City
book signing Monday night,
after Schultz said
he is seriously considering
a possible Independent run
for the White House --
a move that many Democrats fear
could split the anti-Trump vote
and help re-elect
the president.
-I am seriously considering
running for president
as a centrist
Independent.
And I wanted to clarify
the word "Independent,"
which I view merely as
a designation on the ballot.
-Don't help elect Trump,
you egotistical
billionaire [bleep]!
-Damn.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It is not good
when people are yelling at you
at your first
campaign event.
He's like a stand-up comedian
who gets heckled
before he's even
told a joke.
"How's everybody
doing tonight?"
"You suck!"
By the way,
that event was at
the Barnes and Noble
in Union Square,
which has a Starbucks
in it.
He got heckled
in one of his own stores.
That's like if the Colonel
showed up at KFC
and got his head dunked
in the fryer.
[ Laughter ]
There is virtually no appetite
for a billionaire businessman
to run for president
right now.
I guess somebody really put
a stink on that genre.
[ Laughter ]
Running as a billionaire now
is like saying,
"We should do a music festival
with Ja Rule on an island."
[ Laughter, cheers ]
And instead of making a case
for why he should be president,
Schultz has been going after
Democrats like Elizabeth Warren,
Kamala Harris,
Bernie Sanders,
and even
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez.
-In order to run
as a Democrat today,
you have to fall in line with
free Medicare for everybody --
free --
free college for everybody.
I don't think
their views represent
the majority
of Americans.
I don't think we want
a 70% income tax in America.
When I see Elizabeth Warren
come out with, you know,
a ridiculous plan of taxing
wealthy people a surtax of 2%
because it makes a good
headline, or sends out a tweet,
when she knows for a fact
that's not something
that's ever gonna be passed --
this is what's wrong.
You just played --
Senator Harris is saying
she wants to abolish
the insurance industry.
That's --
That's not correct.
That's not American.
What's next?
What industry are we
going to abolish next?
The coffee industry?
-No, dude.
There's a difference,
for one thing.
You can make coffee
at home.
But every time I try to
home-brew some insulin,
my lab rat has a seizure.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, you think people
are gonna vote for you?
You over them, because you're
the C.E.O. of a coffee company?
Personally, I'm more of
a Dunkin' Donuts guy,
but that doesn't mean
I'm gonna vote for the C.E.O. --
who I assume is just
a drunk guy in a Bruins jersey
chucking snowballs
off a highway overpass.
[ Laughter, applause ]
"Check out our
cro-sandwiches!"
[ Laughter ]
If Schultz really doesn't like
the current Democratic field,
he could just run against them
in a Democratic primary.
But he wants to bypass
the process
because he thinks
he's entitled to it.
That's right --
the guy who ran Starbucks
doesn't want
to wait in line.
But Schultz doesn't even
seem to know
the basic facts
about how elections work.
In an interview on
"60 Minutes," for example,
he pledged to get on the ballot
in all 50 states.
But then, he said something
that made no sense.
-If I decide to run
for president,
not only will I be on the ballot
of every state --
all 50 states --
but will be on the ballot in
every county and every district.
-What?
If you're on the ballot
in the state,
you're on the ballot
in every county and district
in that state.
Every county and every district
isn't a presidential plan.
It's a Starbucks
expansion plan.
And we don't want a president
who can't separate
his last job
from his current job.
This guy was a builder.
Now, all he does is talk about
building a wall.
Instead of healthcare,
what are you gonna give us?
Cake pops?
[ Laughter ]
So, Schultz's initial rollout
has not gone well,
which meant Trump couldn't help
but comment on it.
Because when Trump sees someone
getting attention
for doing something dumb,
he gets jealous,
and does something dumber.
And earlier this week,
he attacked Schultz in a tweet.
-"Howard Schultz doesn't have
the guts to run for president.
Watched him on '60 Minutes'
last night,
and I agree with him that
he's not the smartest person.
Besides,
America already has that.
I only hope that Starbucks
is still paying me their rent
in Trump Tower."
-Okay, first of all --
why would anyone in New York
go to the Starbucks
in Trump Tower?
There's two
on every block.
That's like going to a Mets game
just for the Shake Shack.
The food might be good,
but you've still got to
watch the Mets.
Second,
Trump just admitted
he still makes money
from his businesses.
You're supposed to lie, and say
your business is separate.
If Vladimir Putin announced that
he was running for president,
Trump would tweet, "I hope
he's still paying me bribes."
[ Laughter ]
When Trump sees a grift,
he can't help but get in on it,
because he's
a life-long grifter.
And the thing about grifters is,
they attract other grifters.
That's why Trump's campaign
and White House
are filled with
scam artists.
His personal lawyer set up
a secret slush fund
to take bribes,
his first
National Security Adviser
was lobbying for a foreign
government on the side,
and his acting Attorney General
had a scam company
that helped sell
hot tubs.
I'm pretty sure
that's how Trump found him.
[ As Trump ] "Hello.
I'd like to order a hot tub.
Also, by any chance,
are you a lawyer?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] You've got
all these grifters
surrounding
the president.
And even when they leave,
the grift doesn't end.
That's when they try
to sell us books
full of inside dirt
about the Trump White House.
The latest attempt comes from
a guy named Cliff Sims,
who worked in
the White House
as Trump's director
of message strategy.
His new book
about the White House
is called
"Team of Vipers."
In the books,
Sims reveals details
of Trump's interactions
with other Republicans,
like former House Speaker
Paul Ryan.
Sims relays a story
about what happened
the rare time Ryan said
he disagreed with Trump.
Trump called up Ryan,
and yelled at him.
-The book also goes on
to describe the president
reacting to Ryan
distancing himself from Trump
in October 2016,
in the aftermath of
the Access Hollywood tape.
Quote, "I remember
being in Wisconsin,
and your own people were booing
you," Trump told Ryan.
"You were out there dying
like a dog, Paul -- like a dog."
-What does Trump have
against dogs?
He's always attacking people
by saying they were
"fired like dog,"
or "choked like a dog,"
or they were
"begging for money like a dog,"
or they got "kicked out of
the ABC News debate like a dog."
Dogs don't...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dogs don't do
any of those things.
And if a dog got up on a stage
at a debate with you,
not only would it not get booed,
it would probably get elected.
[ Laughter ]
But here's the thing --
Sims still says he was proud
to work for Trump. In fact,
he went so far as to say
that Trump doesn't have
a racist bone in his body.
If that's the case,
it's because he doesn't have
any bones in his body
at all.
I mean, look at him.
I didn't think it was possible
for someone to look like
a sad version of
the Kool-Aid man.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh...no.
Oh, no.
Sorry about you wall."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, in an interview with
the New York this week,
staff writer
Isaac Chotiner
asked Sims
a very simple question
about Trump's
racist crusade
to prove that Barack Obama
was not born in America.
But Sims didn't want to answer,
because he knew it would
contradict his claim
that Trump isn't a racist.
So, the resulting conversation
went in circles forever.
Here are some highlights.
"What's your understanding
or birtherism?"
"What do you mean?
Like, what do you mean,
what's my understanding of it?"
"What the president
was doing there."
"I have no idea."
"Oh."
"I don't really know
what that was all about."
"You are selling yourself
as a smart D.C. insider,
and yet, you are telling me
here, on the record,
that you have no idea
what that was about?
Is that really
what you are doing?"
"I know what it was about."
"So, what do you think
it was about?"
"I don't know."
"Really?
You don't know?"
"I guess I'm confused
at what you were asking."
"You keep saying you know
what birtherism is about,
but you are not telling me
what you think it was about.
So, what do you think
it is about?"
"So, I think that's, like,
a great example of time
where he does not
step up to the plate
and take on these race issues
in an appropriate way,
a helpful way,
for the country.
No doubt that
that was terrible.
I don't know what else
you want me to say about it."
"We have been talking
for five minutes about this,
and it took you that long
to say that?
I mean, geez, I've heard
people more comfortable
getting a full cavity search
at the airport.
What do you mean,
you're not following
the line of questioning?
The question was,
'What is birtherism?'
Were your high-school essays
this bad?"
[ Laughter ]
Trump is the most famous
grifter in politics.
But like all grifters,
he attracts other grifters.
They're just as complicit
in his agenda as anyone else,
even though he's an...
-"Egotistical,
billionaire [bleep]."
This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]